durante más de 30 años en su programa de
cocina el chef antuán ha sido fiel a las
recetas tradicionales de la cocina
libanesa reconocida en todo el mundo
ahora sustituye sus platos con
ingredientes más económicos en carne
roja para poder adoptarlos a los
tratados bolsillos de las familias de
vanesas
decidí cambiar mis recetas siempre
utilizaba carne de res pollo pescado
blanco o salmón pero con el colapso
económico la carne más barata que era la
vacuna se ha vuelto un producto de lujo
los consejos y secretos de cocina chef
and Twain sirven de inspiración a
mujeres como Josephine para poder
sobrevivir al hiperinflación de los
productos alimenticios con su sueldo en
la devaluada libre libanesa le alcanza
para comprar los productos básicos Así
que ha dejado cocinar este guiso con
caldo casero de carne que sustituye por
pasta de tomate concentrado y el arroz
lo acompaña con verduras y papas antes
no cocinábamos así en el Líbano tengo
dos hijos y no puedo darles una dieta
sana y equilibrada como la que solíamos
tener estoy preocupada por su
crecimiento y concentración
la decisión del gobierno quitar los
subsidios a las importaciones de bienes
básicos de alimentos por la crisis
económica también afectado a la cadena
de distribución En esta carnicería la
venta carne roja ha caído alrededor de
un 70% porque los precios se han
quintoplicado
estamos comprando un 20% menos de lo que
adquiríamos cuando la carne era
subsidiada y las ventas a restaurantes
supermercados y clientes son muy bajas
la hiperinflación en la caída de las
importaciones no son los únicos
problemas que afectan a los bienes de
consumo a husein consultor de
exportaciones le preocupa que haya
bajado la calidad de las mercancías
alimentarias ya no importamos carne roja
de Australia ni lácteos europeos
nuestros mercados son ahora el Turco o
Países Árabes que venden más barato pero
de peor calidad conocida como la
coherente medio por Su riqueza y
variedad de alimentos la cocina libanesa
se ha hecho Popular en todo el mundo
pero la crisis económica está poniendo
en peligro siglos de tradición de la
buena comida libanesa